Santos has finally slapped back just a
little bit I roll out of bed I have
people attacking me from all angles it's
been happening for many many years and
if you look at the good thing about it
is when you're an elected executive you
have to make all kinds of decisions you
got to steer that ship and the good
thing is is that the people are able to
render a judgment on that whether they
re-elect you or not and I'm happy to say
you know in my case not only did we win
re-election we won with the highest
percentage of the vote that any
Republican governor candidate has in the
history of the State of Florida and
there it is now we have the DeSantis
sales pitch straight from the man
himself and the sales pitch is at least
I can get elected that's the pitch
Trump's sales pitch is forget about them
they're the wannabes I'm the real deal
and now desantis's answer is yeah well
at least I can get elected